thank you Rocky well the tag Spirit
awards are back and there's a lot to
cheers to here with us today is tag
founder and master mixologist Tony
abuganum Tony so great to see you again
Hey Jillian always a pleasure seeing you
my friend you're a friend of the show
now we always love having you and the
tag Spirit Awards they are a big deal
tell us about them this year yeah this
is second annual um being held at the
Delano we're in the throes of judging
right now we have over a hundred Spirit
categories that we're judging I had to
sneak away from the judging to come make
a drink with you but it all ends up on
Friday with the pink tie party up at
Skyfall it's going to be fantastic over
20 supplier partners with some of the
city's finest bartenders mixing drinks
so get your tickets for the pink and
you're dressed for it Jillian you gave
me the apron so we need business today
we'll see if that helps me with my
bartending skills those are very much a
beautiful pink dress underneath but yes
we're ready to go I'm glad that you
snuck away because it's really important
to not only spread the word about this
but just show that there is really is an
art form to making a cocktail it's not a
simple task right things have changed so
dramatically here in Las Vegas as far as
cocktails and cocktail preparation go
and use of great ingredients and some of
the great bartenders that reside here
the usbg is an amazing chapter and you
know the Helen David Relief Fund which
is being benefited by at the pink Thai
party benefits bartenders going through
cancer treatment so all the proceeds
from the pink type party on Friday night
at Skyfall go to the usbg Helen David
relief funds well that's really special
that you are giving back to those who
need it the most but hey we're here to
talk drinks right so put me to work what
are we making okay what we're going to
make today is a classic old-fashioned
and it's featuring one of last year's
um uh tag Spirit Awards winning Bourbons
this is from Woody Creek and Woody Creek
Colorado this is actually a single
barrel that we bought five properties of
MGM we just had the Lions Den cocktail
competition on Sunday yes Denise was a
judge it was fantastic I bet the winning
drink will be featured at all five
properties featuring this whiskey so
you're going to get a sneak preview all
right we're adding it in oh you're
letting me know you're going to do the
mixing okay
the sweetener is a little gum syrup with
gum arabic was that too much I don't
know if you saw I have to keep going
keep going
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right we're finishing up here I
gotta take a sip of this but the tag
awards are happening there's a few
tickets left for this weekend
um I got a cheers to you Tony thanks for
always coming by making my pleasure this
drink it's always so much fun with you
cheers and there's all the information
on your screen for the 2023 tag at
Global Spirit Awards happening through
the weekend